this is a production of Cornell
University
and first off today live from Mexico
we're going to have Marga Kraus to tell
us about leveraging Ariel high
throughput phenotyping for improved
early generation selection and we'd take
it away to start off giving a little
background on Ariel - Oh typing this
relies heavily on the concept of light
reflected off of the crop canopy and
recent developments in the remote
sensing imaging and aerospace industries
have given us a wide range of
technologies to use to acquire these
phenotypes and we're using quite a
number of them here at CIMMYT to look at
different problems in plant breeding and
genetics but today I will just be
focusing on unmanned aerial systems or
UAS s as well as multi spectral sensors
which give us reflectance at a small
number of wavelengths in the light
spectrum in our case we get five and
from this information we can calculate
what are called vegetation indices it's
been well characterized in the
literature that vegetation indices can
be useful proxies for things like
overall plant health response to stress
changes in phenology etc so we're
interested in those for potentially
using them to select at the early stage
and wheat I am calculating and working
with quite a number of them but for this
presentation I'll just be working with
NDVI which is a ratio of reflectance in
the near infrared and red regions of the
spectrum so a little bit of background
on the Senate breeding programs some of
you might be familiar with their method
of selected so plants are selected in
both between the F 2 and F 5 generations
and the F 6 is really the first time
when they're selected and harvested
individually and then they're planted in
small to raw plots and that are one
meter in length and these are
unreplicated um a couple weeks ago we
just finished hand planting 38,000
so it's a lot of work and we could
theoretically measure granules at the
stage but trait heritability is low and
not reliable for selection in addition
we don't really have the machine or
manpower to harvest and way that many
samples so at this stage we're still
working with visual selection and then
those lines move on into the first year
of replicated yield trials it could
potentially be beneficial to have
accurate predictions of green yield at
the f7 small plot stage and that's what
we're trying to look at with aerial
phenotyping so we've kind of designed an
experiment to ask this question can we
use phenotyping to select at the early
generation stage and we design the
experiment so that it would be kind of
integrated into the breeding program and
not use a lot of extra resources so the
breeders went through the f7 small plots
in 2016 to select lines to move on into
the large replicated yield trials in
2017 we went through and selected a
subset of those 1080 lines and planted
them again it's unreplicated one meter
small plots so these line these lines
were planted twice in 2016 both small
plots and as large yield plots we used
to mitrice 100 UAS by DJI equipped with
a micro sense red edge multispectral
sensor to phenotype the plots at
multiple time points during the growing
season we also assessed yield in both
the small and large plots again we don't
normally assess yield and small plot so
we did so this year for the purpose of
this experiment I want to take you guys
through some of the steps of the aerial
phenotyping and imaging pipeline that we
use at CIMMYT because there are a lot of
considerations that we have to get right
in order to get usable phenotype out at
the end before we can even fly there are
a few things to do and one of those
things is to make and place ground
control points in the field these need
to stay in one place throughout the
growing season and they need to be
visible to the sensor once we've
collected their RTK GPS coordinates with
our RTK system we can use that
information to
signed physical locations to each of the
images which is critical to being able
to stitch them together we also need to
create a flight plan for the UAS and we
do that in a software called mission
planner again in order to stitch the
images they have to have sufficient
overlap so we shoot for 80% overlap and
75% side lap and we can program that
into the flight plan the altitude speed
of the UAS and capture rate of the
sensor can also affect the overall
quality of the image and we fly the mic
ascents at 30 meters at 12 km/h and the
sensor has a capture rate of one image
per second on the day of the flight
there's a lot of things to remember to
bring out to the field batteries are
actually a big bottleneck for us we
bring out multiple SD cards for the
images and a computer to store them on
at the end um we run an app on a tablet
that will control the UAV and it runs
the flight plan mostly automatically so
this very little manual control of the
UAS that's needed before every takeoff
we also take images of a calibration
panel calibrating the images is really
important because atmospheric conditions
on the day of the flight can affect the
amount of light that's captured by the
sensor so what we do is we measure the
true values of the calibration panel
with a spectral radiometer and then
compare those two values taken on the
day of the flight and create a model
that will calibrate all of the images
prior to stitching this is really
important if you want to compare
phenotypes on different dates and track
grow throughout the growing season we
stitch all the images together using a
software called pix for D and the
composite image that comes out is called
an ortho mosaic I put up our ortho
mosaic of the small plots area from one
time point and I've taken out a section
for you to see up close what it looks
like that little white thing in there is
a ground control point our final
resolution is one to two centimeters for
pixels so it's pretty good again these
are the 1 meter plots so they're fairly
small
to extract the data we use our GIS and
first thing we a soil vegetation mask
using a maximum likelihood
classification so this will sign a
binary value to pixels that are either
soil or vegetation we can apply that
mask back to the original image and
remove any data associated with soil and
then the last step is to draw polygons
around the plots and calculate plot
level statistics on the data bound by
the polygon so there are a lot of
considerations that go into this and
hopefully if you do it right you can get
a good quality results and that's what
we think we're starting to see here in
both the small and the large plots we
had higher heritability for all of our
MB bi time points than we did for yields
so that's promising in our in terms of
yield we had a correlation of 0.3
between the small and large plots that's
about what we expected and in both
experiments we saw significant
correlations between NDVI and yield it
was a little bit greater in the large
plots due to their size the relationship
that we're really interested in however
is between small plot NDVI and large
flat yield and here we're seeing that
it's 0.4 3 so that's pretty good I
looked at this in terms of correlated
response to selection so in this case
the correlated trait is actually large
flat yield and we could theoretically
select off of small plot you small flat
nd bi or small pot yield and we're
seeing that the NDVI is twice as
effective the reason for this is because
it has higher heritability and it has a
higher correlation with large pot yields
than small pot yield so these are
looking promising as a selection tool I
also did some multi trait genomic
prediction work and this is work sort of
following Jessica's initial work using
hgp traits as secondary traits in gs and
the set up that I use is a little bit
complicated so I wanted to go through it
the training set that I used was 80% of
the lines the target trait was large
flat yield and the secondary trait was
large plot NDVI so we fit this model
using pedigrees and then for the text
that we use the remaining 20% of lines
yield was hidden
this time and small-plot NDVI was
actually the second the secondary trade
so the predictions that we got out we
correlated back to large flat yield so
the idea of doing this is you could fit
a model using the large plots where you
have both yield and NDVI available and
then use it to predict the small plots
where you only have an ABI and assess
what their yield would be as if they
were planted as large plots so I've
plotted the results along the bottom in
white and we're looking at multiple time
points for the NDVI so I tried to show
where those are in relation to the
phenology of the trials that's what the
top two graphs are um CIMMYT has a huge
aerial phenotyping program I think we
did more aerial phenotyping last season
than any CG Center has ever done we have
a lot of different experiments going on
so unfortunately those things as well as
changes in the weather and
responsibilities in the field prevented
us from phenotyping the both trials in
the same date we also had a lot more
phenotyping dates that we had assessed
but several of them didn't make it
through our quality control pipeline so
these are the dates that we have we have
two in the small pots and four in the
large plots you can see in the results
that adding NDB is the secondary rate
doesn't improve over the univariate case
in most cases but it does so twice most
notably when both the small and large
plots for phenotyped on march 13th we
know that NDB is sensitive to phenology
so this coming season we will be paying
a lot more attention to trying to
phenotype these trials at the same time
we got them planted on the exact same
date this year so that's really good we
just want to make sure that we're doing
our best so that we're not comparing
apples oranges one more thing I want to
say about this is in this experiment the
training set and the test set were
assessed within the same breeding cycle
but if we were to do this in practice
the training and test sets would be one
to two breeding cycles removed so it's
possible that what we're seeing here is
a little bit of within cycle
cross-validation bias which is
characterized in the
literature and that NDVI could actually
be more beneficial than what we're
seeing but we have not assessed that yet
so some quick take-home messages the
small plot Arial NDVI traits tend to be
more heritable than yield they are
predictive of yield in the large plots
and they're correlated response is twice
as effective as the small plot yield
with our multi trait GS and EB I does
have the potential to improve accuracy
about timing around the phenology
appears to be really important and we
will be taking steps to improve that
this coming year so that's what I have
for you guys today and I'd like to thank
my committee especially my advisers mark
and Mike at CIMMYT I'm working with dr.
Jose Costa who's in biometrics but as
you can see from the photos there are a
lot of other people who helped make this
phenotyping possible this project has
also been heavily supported by Kansas
State jesse has been Co advising the
project his UAS technician rich brown
who's pictured there taught me how to
fly and attina has been helping with
some of the image processing and of
course I wouldn't be in Mexico without
my funding sources so thank you to USAID
and their us for lab dollars in global
food security grant as well as the
National Science Foundation grant so I'm
happy to interact with you guys for a
couple minutes if we still have time
[Applause]
questions yeah or I could run the mic to
ya tier so don't obrigada
you know when you're taking NDVI images
is the lack of greenness and that kind
of you know being robust for it's not
robust healthy versus not healthy is
that drought heat nitrogen stress all
three of them other things I mean like
what fundamentally is the like yeah I
guess what is it stress tolerance or
stress resistance or whatnot that is
being reflected in NDVI what are you
selecting on like terms of that
yeah so in terms of that for this
particular experiment it's probably just
gonna be a lot to do with biomass in the
small pots you know germination things
like that but we are using these
technologies at CIMMYT in our other
environments and so we have a drought
experiment we have a heat experiment and
in those experiments we see a lot of
difference a lot more variation in NDVI
that would be linked to those things
Margaret this dan could you pull back a
couple slides to the prediction
accuracies on yeah so the on march 13th
do you think the higher prediction
accuracy there is an artifact of being
scored on the same day and large and
small plots because it's just kind of an
arbitrary time in Granville or do you
think that's actually legitimate is that
the time points that tends to be the
most predictive in our program tend to
be during grain filling and we haven't
necessarily focused all of our
phenotyping efforts to just focus on the
grain fill stage because I think the
breeders are interested in having
phenotypes from earlier in the season
certainly it takes time to process the
imagery so to have phenotypes in the
hands of the breeders at the time that
they're going through selections you
might have to start earlier so um that's
something that it'll be interesting to
see what the results come out as next
season if it's only grain filling that
is the time when we can phenotype
effectively well if there's no more
questions let's all thank Margaret
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu